how's it going guys Matt here with code
Tech tutorials today we're going to look
at some C plus plus standard stuff roll
a three it's uh from CBP reference it's
also just a standard that you should
know about with C plus plus but I'm
guessing if you're watching this video
you don't know it yet and I'm just going
to verbally go over it I don't know why
I make these videos sometimes I feel
really goofy just making videos based on
things that are already written like I'm
Reinventing the wheel or something but
no matter some people like these videos
a lot of you seem to so I appreciate
that I'll keep making them if you keep
liking them the rule of three five and
zero what is this about what's the point
well this is all about Constructors and
destructors when you make C plus plus
classes generally you want to follow one
of these rules you should either have
three Constructors five or zero now this
is because compilers tend to do a lot of
work for you so sometimes they don't
quite understand exactly what you want
with your class and that's why you've
got to follow these rules in general so
let's just read it rule of three if a
class requires a user-defined Destructor
a user defined copy Constructor or
user-defined copy assignment operator it
almost certainly requires all three so
let's unpack that it actually talks
about it more here this will probably
explain it because C plus plus copies
and copy assigns objects of user-defined
types in various situations passing
slash returning by value manipulating a
container so this is talking about like
your the private members in your class
and what happens if you make a new
instantiation of your class and set it
equal to a previous one does it copy the
data members or what happens so it's
considering stuff like that the special
member functions will be called if
accessible if they're not user defined
they are implicitly defined by the
compiler that's really important so if
you don't do anything you just make your
class you don't make Constructors or
destructors they are implicitly defined
which means your compiler basically
makes the definitions that it thinks are
fine for default
and you might ask okay well what's the
problem with that well some cases it's
fine that's where the rule of zero is
going to come in but in other cases
where you are managing memory then it's
special it's different because if you
have to define a Destructor it assumes
that somewhere you're using the new
operation in your class like maybe you
have a pointer that gets instantiated
uh when you create a class so of course
when you delete your class you also have
to destruct that piece of data that's
being pointed to you know there's things
like that all right we'll we'll continue
on we'll we're going to kind of drill
this in all right the implicitly defined
special member functions are typically
incorrect if the class manages a
resource whose handle is an object of a
non-class type such as a raw pointer or
file file descriptor whose Destructor
does nothing and copy construction
assignment operation performs a shallow
copy which will copy the value of the
handle without duplicating the
underlying resource so shallow copy
essentially here means hey we're copying
whatever is pointing to the data but not
the actual data itself so this as you
can see this gets into memory management
now if you don't understand it by this
then hopefully this example will make it
a little more clear so let's continue so
here's a chunk of code that is supposed
to make an example of why the rule of
three is a good idea all right so let's
go over this step by step and think
about it all right well I got uh let's
just go to class and the other class the
name the class rule three obviously no
one's going to have a class named rule
of the three ever so yours will vary but
the point is as you'll see well this
first section is private because that's
the classes default they've got a
character pointer called C string
essentially an old version of a string
just a character array which is you know
just a pointer to the first part of it
raw pointer used to handle dynamically
allocated memory blocks so they've got a
dynamically allocated memory block so
yeah this is how you one of the ways you
could do it because of course what it's
pointing to is going to get instantiated
later and Etc so they have a default
Constructor here well not entirely
default it takes a pointer
to another another character
um so this could be another array of who
knows what size but they do have to pass
in the size because you don't
automatically know how how many it's
pointing to like this is just the first
one right because it's an array so the
size in all right so they say allocate
so they take the C string and they say
new character array of size n so they
use this size in they're putting this on
the heat
and I'm sorry I didn't mean to say Heap
we're putting this on the stack so stack
is generally instantiated at run time
all right so that's you know there's
more to it than that but if you're using
new and making some kind of pointer data
it's pretty safe to assume that it's
going on this deck okay so they do that
and then they do a mem copy
and they're putting the data from s
right this one they're passing in
putting it into the C string and of
course mem copy needs a size so they're
essentially copying whatever this array
is in to the new one but first they had
to make the new one the right size
because it's Dynamic all right so we got
some you know it's all private here but
we have some memory management that's
the point and mem copy sure it's an old
it's an old C function but it's still
widely used because well reasons all
right so that's the private stuff you
can see we're dynamically allocating
when we destruct this class we are going
to have to free this
um C string here this data so right now
you're definitely going to need a
Destructor so if you're going to need a
user-defined Destructor then you're also
going to need a copy Constructor and
you're also going to need a copy
assignment operator
that's the rule of three if you need any
of those you need all three and we'll
continue to explain why and drill home
all right so here are the public
functions so there's only a few ways to
instantiate or to initialize this class
and that is these three operations here
so since this one appears private nobody
can actually call this but we'll get to
that here shortly because uh you'll see
how it works out basically you call this
front-end one here called Rule of three
and you can pass it a character pointer
which is essentially some character
array if you don't pass it anything it
just it makes it one blank character or
it will just be null terminated
immediately
so they've got a default here if you
don't know what the defaults are well
it's a C plus plus thing that says if
you don't pass in a value it's just
going to assume that the value is
whatever this equals so this is the
Constructor you actually use when you
make your class and you can see it
doesn't actually do anything in its body
all it does is call the other
Constructor that we already went over
right here so it will do this nice deep
mem copy of whatever you pass in
so that's what it does you you just
instantiate it give it a pointer to a
character or not and it'll just be blank
and uh you can see there are calls you
know it passes in this s for this one
here and this calculates the size using
string length plus one to pass into that
size and uh there we go that's a very
basic Constructor
and that's all fine there and now we
need a Destructor why do we need a
Destructor well we already kind of went
over that but basically because this is
a pointer to dynamically allocated
memory so you gotta custom free it it's
not going to just free itself when it
goes out of scope well the pointer will
free itself when it goes out of scope of
the data is going to sit there till you
delete it so you definitely need a
deleted
and uh there it is there's our
Destructor and as you can see we call
delete array on C string that should
free all of that data uh that is in that
C string all right so what else do we
need we well we got a basic Constructor
uh we got a Destructor very good
but really the rule three is talking
about these three right here I mean the
basic Constructor is fine that is often
you know having a basic Constructor is
not enough to talk about the rule of
three the rule of three is very specific
to Destructor copy Constructor and copy
assignment so keep that in mind and
those are the ones if you have any of
these three you're gonna need the other
two so I know I'm drilling that point
home but that's literally the point of
the rule three so if you don't get that
you're missing everything so that's why
I'm just saying it over and over okay so
here we go here's a copy Constructor how
do you make a copy Constructor when you
pass and the other one by reference and
you make sure it's const why by
reference well because it's fast why
const because this is a copy Constructor
which means we are definitely not doing
anything with the other one we want to
make sure we don't do the move operation
we could accidentally be doing a move if
it's not cost but cons says you're not
allowed to do anything with the other
data if you want it you're going to copy
it so great so copy by reference
uh fast as it gets pretty much and as
you can see it just calls the basic
Constructor with the other string so
this if you use this Constructor it's
gonna
go to here and then it's of course going
to go to here and it'll work correctly
with a nice deep copy and then we have a
copy assignment now this is the equals
operator how do you do the equals
operator well you got to return a
reference to your class
first of all and then you do operator
equals and then you once again just like
this copy one you want to reference
that's const that way you can make sure
you uh are doing a copy and not some
weird move operation or something all
right and we just have some Logic for
the equal first of all if we say
well if we're trying to copy another
class and it's already the already the
same with a little equals equals check
here then just return the class already
it's already the same so but if not if
we go past this if they're not already
equal when you set them equal
then it goes through a whole operation
first of all it's got to get to size it
needs a new size so it does the whole
string length on the other one checks
its size so it's instantiating in there
the proper size then we're going to make
a new string just temporary one well
it's not a string it's a character
pointer so it's an array of characters
string array of characters basically the
same thing in some ways so we just set
it equal to a new character of that size
this allocates the memory
but it doesn't fill it out yet we got to
do that mem copy to populate it and then
what is why are we deleting the uh this
one here or what what's going on here
well this is only deleting what was
previously in string so uh the reason
we're deleting here is because well we
haven't actually used this one yet this
is just preparing basically
we we take this other C string
and we're copying it into our new
temporary variable then we're going to
clear whatever we had before with delete
and we're going to
set it to the new one and then we return
our class as required so as you can see
here we have to do a little bit of
careful work on a lot of these
um mainly this mem copy and just
managing this memory so the rule three
here is really all about memory
management if you've got a private
pointer that's dynamically allocated in
your class you probably probably need to
follow the rule three here's a main
using it first of all they instantiate
rule of three with the data ABC then
they do a c out of it that's fine then
they make another one and they use a
initializer list here which is going to
use a copy Constructor because they're
feeding the new rule of three class and
old ones so what's that going to do here
well with a
with a list here it's essentially going
to use this operator right here when it
constructs it so it's going to take that
other one and call a base Constructor
which will go up here and then it will
go here and it'll do a deep copy as as
you think it would right there
all right and then they do another C out
of the new one then they make a third
one and they call it deaf and then
they're gonna set they're gonna use the
equal operator or the copy assignment to
set the third one equal to what the two
one was so that's gonna call this method
right here
you see we got the other one they're not
going to be equal so it's going to fly
through that it's going to allocate that
new string just temporarily right there
it's going to delete whatever O3
previously had which will be the def
that'll delete it right there and then
it's going to set it equal finally
to the old one now notice that you know
we already did the copying right here so
the very last part is just saying hey
put the pointer in the right place
basically put our C string pointer equal
to this one so this part right here just
makes a pointer assignment since the
date is already chill in there somewhere
else so interesting stuff and and that's
that's basically it now I didn't expect
this video to quite take as long as it
has so
I think I'll make separate videos for
the rule of five and zero and just
continue them after this but uh
hopefully we've drilled home the point
of the rule of three for using that
Destructor copy Constructor copy
assignment if you need one you need the
other three and here's just a nice
little example of course in your stuff
your data is going to be different but
just keep that in mind
cut stuff like this got a pointer
privately being instantiated it's a good
chance you're gonna need to follow the
rule three all right stay tuned for more